if you're excited for Super Mario run  I've got some good news for you I'm Tony  and this is your mobile gamespot news  update Super Mario run now has an  official release date and price first  it's important to know that the game has  three modes one involves collecting  coins one involves racing ghosts of  other players and the last is a special  mode that lets you create your own  Mushroom Kingdom whatever that means the  initial download lets you try these  modes for free but it'll cost you ten  bucks for unlimited access you'll be  able to jump in on December 15 Super  Mario run will work with any iPhone iPad  or iPod Touch running iOS 8 or later and  it'll be available in 151 different  countries at launch stay tuned to  gamespot for more coverage when that  happens and for all the biggest Mario  news you're already in the right place